one day we want to take humanity
into space but why don't we start
small take one solar power station
10 000 people and 10 million tons of
crumbled moon rock and
you get a space habitat a stanford
taurus
how would this habitat work who would be
allowed to live there
and how would it help to reverse climate
change
on earth this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we built
a stanford taurus
we've already hypothesized about living
on an o'neill cylinder
a dyson sphere even a matroshka brain
how would this habitat be any different
[Music]
for one its size a stanford taurus would
be about 60 times
smaller than an o'neill cylinder and
it's
much much smaller than a dyson sphere
to build a stanford taurus we'd need to
mine the moon a little
the moon is a perfect mining candidate
because it has
oxygen in its rocks that we could use to
make a breathable atmosphere
and manufacture water it has silica we'd
use for windows and solar cells
it also has aluminum that would work
perfectly for construction
but of course securing the materials is
only the beginning
we'd start assembling the habitat in
space between the moon
and the earth it would have to be close
enough to the moon so that we could
easily transport the materials
it would also need to be far enough from
the earth that it wouldn't fall into our
planet's orbit
our stanford taurus would look like a
bicycle wheel
and the spokes would join together at
the center
the inhabitants would live in the tire
section
but before we bring people in we need to
create a proper environment
and life support to imitate the earth's
gravity
we'd make the habitat complete a full
spin on its axis
every minute the centrifugal force would
make
up for the weightlessness you normally
experience in space
because you don't want things to float
around
the habitat would get all its sunlight
beamed down by a large
mirror stationed directly over the hub
at a 45 degree angle
it would direct solar rays into the
smaller mirrors
on the outer shell of the taurus those
mirrors would also act as part of the
shield from all the harmful cosmic
radiation
living in this space habitat would be
like living in a small town
there would be no skyscrapers only labs
high-tech farms and
housing most of the people living on the
stanford tourists would be scientists or
engineers
farmers or space construction workers
they'd take up a permanent residence on
the taurus with their families where
they would live a sustainable colony
life
the population of the stanford tourists
would be limited to
about 10 000 people all the inhabitants
would be strictly selected through
extensive tests and training
but we wouldn't just build the habitat
for the sake of it
the stanford taurus would benefit deep
space research and
act as a maintenance and construction
point for satellite solar power stations
the solar power stations would provide
for all the colony's energy needs and
would have the potential to supply
energy to earth as well
we'd beam solar energy down with lasers
or microwave emitters
then we would collect that energy above
the earth's atmosphere
having so much solar generated power we
wouldn't need to burn any fossil fuels
give it enough time and our planet might
just recover from climate change
but all that wouldn't be cheap the cost
of a stanford taurus would come to some
900 billion dollars but
we could minimize a large chunk of that
cost by
using reusable spacex rockets to send
people to space
eventually we'd start building more
habitats and explore
more of the solar system we'd build a
lunar base
and then set a course for mars
but before you sign up for that mission
you need to have a good survival
strategy
in case something goes wrong and we have
a show for you that covers just that
to help you survive whatever awaits